rejection is never easy but it's so much
worse when it happens in the public eye
where the humiliation is documented for
all to see
for actors forming crushes with co-stars
or other celebrities makes a lot of
sense
they work closely with one another they
understand the pressures that come with
the terrain
but the flip side of having a very
public crush is that when you get
rejected
it also happens in a very public and
very painful way
here are 15 actors who had their
celebrity crushes rejected
you should go who doesn't love a bad boy
especially when you're 12.
our favorite witch hermione may have
felt otherwise but emma watson has
admitted that between the age 10 and 12
she had a really terrible crush on tom
felton he was a few years older and he
had a skateboard
wow and that just did it who can resist
a skateboard
but unfortunately for emma he only saw
her in a sisterly way despite her
obvious crush
thankfully they've been able to remain
great friends over the years but i guess
we'll
always wonder what could have been a
little-known fact about
dancing with the stars icons and
siblings derek and julianne huff
is that they were extras in the first
harry potter film over the two months
they spent shooting harry potter and the
philosopher's stone
julianne developed a huge crush on star
daniel radcliffe
she even sent him a love letter and a
beanie baby for valentine's day but he
never responded
jules said that she had to go through an
assistant and couldn't get it to him
directly
she still feels embarrassed about the
whole thing but who can blame her for
having a crush on the boy who lived
she's only interested in you because she
thinks you're the chosen one
but i am the chosen one everyone knows
leonardo dicaprio has a type
and cara delevingne seems to fit the
bill so given leo's penchant for models
it's no surprise that he chased after
cara pretty hard during an after party
at the 2013 cannes film festival
he was there celebrating his role in the
great gatsby but seemed more interested
in gaining kara's affections
according to insiders though kara wasn't
interested maybe it's time leo focuses
on finding a model his own age
i'm not gonna answer that question i
like to keep my private life private
one woman's loss is another woman's gain
so it seemed at least when taylor swift
apparently made a move on bradley cooper
after his split with zoe saldana in
2013.
it all happened at the golden globes
where taylor asked her friend jennifer
lawrence to make the introduction
since she and bradley co-starred in the
silver linings playbook
but bradley rejected taylor preferring
someone his own age and looking for
something a little more serious
if only leonardo dicaprio could take a
page out of bradley cooper's book
josh hutcherson had a major crush on
emma watson
who doesn't honestly well other than tom
felton
hutcherson even went so far as to ask
his manager to get in touch with her
manager in order to set up a meeting
between the two actors
sadly for him nothing came of it i had
like the most embarrassing moment
i think of my entire life maybe he
should have tried the direct route
it hasn't happened yet one day fingers
crossed he said
poor josh it's been seven years since he
revealed his crush so safe to say that
one day
probably won't come anytime soon when
hilary duff and aaron carter were
fresh-faced and just starting out
they actually dated for a time it makes
sense both were teen idols and
aaron even made an appearance on lizzie
mcguire more than a decade later though
aaron seems to have trouble letting go
of the past
he publicly declared his love for
hillary duff on multiple occasions
even tweeting about how he'll spend the
rest of his life trying to get back to
her
asked about it on watch what happens
live with andy cohen hillary was pretty
uncomfortable it was so many years ago
right i literally haven't seen him and
so it's uncomfortable
and speaking of aaron carter's exes
lindsay lohan also makes the cut of
actors who've rejected other stars
now if harry styles showed up at your
door in the middle of the night would
you turn him away
who in their right mind would well
lindsay lohan apparently
do i know you the superstar singer
supposedly showed up at lindsay's hotel
room one night at two in the morning
surprisingly lindsay says she didn't
recognize him and had no idea who he was
or why he was there
so she simply said good night and sent
him away
the vamp singer james mcvay and game of
thrones actress sophie turner briefly
dated in 2014
but then things got a little messy on
twitter sophie ultimately tweeted
asking him to please stop texting me
it's getting creepy and i'm sorry
i'm not interested thank god the
internet is there to document the messy
breakup forever
i'm gonna go years later mcveigh claimed
the whole thing was a joke between the
two and wished sophie happiness with now
husband joe jonas but it seems a little
bit like he was trying to backtrack
now that sophie has moved on for the
better nicole kidman appeared on the
tonight show in 2015 and spilled to
jimmy fallon that she'd had an
unrequited crush on him when they first
met years earlier
she thought they were meeting for a date
but jimmy thought it was a meet-up to
discuss working together so he totally
failed to impress her
and then you put a video game on or
something and
she took it as him having no interest
talk about a missed connection
fallon was floored when nicole revealed
she'd been interested in him
all those years ago what
are you talking about poor jimmy didn't
even realize he'd blown his chance to
date nicole kidman
but both are happily married so it
seemed to work out for the best
next up taylor swift and brenton
thwaites both starred in the giver in
2014
which of course sent up rumors left and
right that the two were dating
especially after they both appeared in a
photo together at the toronto
international film festival
the waits cleared things up though
saying it was surreal that people
thought they were together
we know taylor is a bit of a serial
dater so it makes sense she would go
after a hunky co-star
but still having someone publicly
announce their disinterest has gotta
hurt
brenton and i just go to jeff's room and
play guitar with him and speaking of
public humiliation
aziz anzari told the story of how blake
lively rejected him on howard stern's
talk show
according to aziz the two supposedly
traded phone numbers at an event way
back in 2011
after he learned that blake was a fan of
his work aziz texted her afterward but
never even got a response
being ghosted by the person you're into
is another level of painful
who knows if that was even her real
phone number but blake is now happily
married to ryan reynolds so it's safe to
say
she's not feeling any regrets first
texts 4 11 am
i love alcohol the young stars of
netflix to all the boys i've loved
before
reportedly had a mighty powerful spark
off-screen as well as on
according to lana condor who plays lead
character lara jean
the two actors were hanging out at
noah's apartment having pizza
and she felt something for him
unfortunately though she told him
noah it's not going to happen between us
it's one thing to be rejected by someone
else but stepping in and drawing a line
in spite of your desires is kind of
commendable
they agreed to be mature and keep things
professional but the spark is
definitely still there in an interview
with buzzfeed tiffany haddish was asked
what she would do
if she met her celebrity crush her
answer she already had
and being as bold as she is she straight
up asked her crushes out on a date they
all turned me down
you ever know him i could be george
that's rough but we can't help but
admire tiffany's openness and tenacity
better to rip the bandage off and have
an answer than pine away
jennifer lawrence has been pretty open
about her love of funny men
she said she's been in love with
seinfeld creator larry david for a
really long time
despite the fact that he's more than
twice her age she's so smitten with the
comedian that she even gave him her
phone number once
sadly he never called but jennifer
didn't even mind the rejection saying
i love that he didn't call me it makes
him so much hotter she said she had a
crush on you
uh-huh and she said she also had a crush
on me
salma hayek has the lovely distinction
of having rejected the president
of the united states donald trump of
course he wasn't always president
there was a more innocent time when he
was mostly just known for firing people
on tv
apparently trump befriended selma's
boyfriend at an event and got both of
their numbers
then he seemingly forgot about her
boyfriend because he started just
calling up selma and asking her out to
dinner
she declined but trump insisted selma's
boyfriend wasn't good enough for her i
kept saying no
what i said didn't you see that i have a
boyfriend he goes like he's not good
enough for you
as tough as it is to be rejected by your
crush we should all be grateful we don't
have to go through it publicly
which of these crushes and rejections
surprised you the most drop a comment
below and don't forget to subscribe to
the things for more awesome videos
thanks for watching
[Music]